i i want to thank you as i always have
for
being
the earliest supporter of my
choice to try to become a professional
idiot
like uh really cindy was was behind me
before anybody else was when was that
choice made i made that choice
officially in 1993
when i dropped out of the university of
miami i was couch surfing for three
years and ended up moving in with my
sister in albuquerque new mexico
and uh she she was behind me what was
that what was the choice to become a
professional idiot i was gonna beat i
was trying to become a famous stuntman
by videotaping
idiotic stunts with my home video camera
there was no precedent for that cindy
was a supporter she let me live in her
house and she found out about to
tell that a little bit about how you
feel about the way i
uh tell the story of
you taking a dump and
is that accurate it is
um so in albuquerque i was the city hall
reporter and um we had a little bureau
downtown separate from the main
city hall uh or sorry the main newspaper
office
and um there were five of us in this
downtown bureau uh and the albuquerque
tribune albuquerque journal or the
albuquerque journal yeah tribune was the
enemy that was that was the rival um but
uh
we had this bathroom and um one of the
the reporters there had put like a
little table with some flowers in it and
you know it was it was pretty cozy
because there were just five of us in
this office and we had like an
lounging chair and a couple of other
things and there were some magazines and
there was a trivia book in the bathroom
and this was before cell phones this
would have been
1995
96 96 okay so cell phones weren't really
you know a thing you didn't take your
phone into the bathroom with you and it
actually would have been i moved to
albuquerque in 96 but this would have
been 97. okay
um
so
you know
in the era before cell phones if you
were
planning on spending more than just a
couple of seconds in the bathroom you
might pick up whatever was lying around
and so i often would read some of the
trivia things um
just
passing time
um and
one of the
little items
was what is um you know one of the only
universities or colleges in the country
that doesn't have any tuition
um and is statistically harder to get
into than harvard or maybe that's
something you came up with later but
um and it was the ringling brothers
barnum bailey clown college in sarasota
that had auditions
you know throughout the year for each
class and then um didn't charge any
tuition
and i thought reeling brothers barnum
bailey clown college like
that could be a way to legitimize all
like that could be awesome because at
the time you had
signed up you'd been out out of school
but i'd encouraged you to um sign up at
unm and you took a gymnastics class yeah
and that was when and you really wanted
the standing back flip and you worked
really hard on it and you got it
um
and uh you'd always done a couple of bar
tricks for beer because you know
um
but you went to
the uh we found out that um i did some
research i found out there were
auditions coming up and
yeah you tell the story better than i do
well i remember
the very same day you took the dump
it all started when i you know yeah when
my sister was taking a dump
and uh
i came home from school i was in in the
university and i came home there was a
note on the kitchen table it said
ringling brothers barnum and bailey
clown college apparently tuition is free
if you can get in and i still saved that
note i still have it and um so i i okay
well this is cool and i called up
the the phone number and
um
i think it was just a voicemail that
said i was getting ready to tell him oh
how i'm a rad stunt man
it was just a voicemail saying if you
want an audition schedule then leave uh
your address and and so i left the
address and
didn't think about it too much and then
uh when the
audition schedule came in the mail i had
been
i wasn't home i i was on ryan
simonetti's floor barfing all over his
carpet like with alcohol poisoning i've
seen the footage i think of that yeah
the one where i'm at the top of the
stairs
and so i was very hungover when i came
home to find this piece of mail for me
with
you know the audition schedule and i
looked down it and it said albuquerque
you know for the class of 1998 there's a
cutoff line
i saw albuquerque saw it's not for the
next it's not until next year so
whatever and i just was hung over and i
just put it back down i went to go smoke
pot at my buddy's house
and then when i came home i walked in
cindy was very stern
she says how are you getting to denver
by monday
she insisted yeah why because you were
such a good roommate because i bought
because above the line there was an
audition for uh college were you
were you before that the type of guy to
say that like because i feel like
nowadays you would have been like oh the
they're not coming to albuquerque for
another year so i'm gonna go to denver
or i'm gonna figure out how to do it
sooner you wouldn't be just like i'll
just i'll just wait then like were you
that type of guy and is cindy kind of
like when you when he said to you
i want to be a crazy stunt man were you
kind of like well okay you're gonna have
to [ __ ] make some [ __ ] happen here
like you gotta get some skills or
something like was it kind of a
you know what i'm saying our dad um
in his youth
sold encyclopedias or something and um
he raised us
there were a couple of quirks in how we
were raised it might not be everybody's
experience
and um
one of the things that he learned that
he passed on to us is that no is a
request for further information
[Laughter]
no just means they obviously didn't
understand the first time so you need to
rephrase i love it um
you know that that
was one of the things we learned so um
we you know the other thing is it
doesn't really matter what you're gonna
do but if you're gonna do it
rock you know like go balls out do
really do it hard um
we don't really half-ass anything
um
you know if you're going to
be a sucker who loves animals
[ __ ] adopt a bajillion of them you
know
whatever it is
do it well
um
because
doing anything half-assed is just
offensive sure yeah so
um so when steve came to you and was
like i want to be this famous stunt man
like i knew you were supportive about
the sort of what are you gonna
yeah right if that's what you want
okay cool what are we going to do about
it right um how can i help you because
that was you know that was always
yeah i remember one of the first things
when we moved to albuquerque i had just
dialed in the standing back flip
and i had taken to pouring alcohol
rubbing alcohol on my skin and lighting
it and using it in my hand as a fire
breathing torch so once i was pouring
rubbing alcohol on my skin and lighting
it on fire i decided oh man i'm going
big i'm gonna
pour rubbing alcohol all over my entire
body
and light my whole body on fire and then
do a standing back flip you know i've
smeared vaseline all over to try to make
it a little bit safer um and and i chose
for my first time doing this stunt which
i pictured being a pretty big one
uh
when the radio station
announced that they were holding a freak
of nature contest so i called up the
radio station that i'm gonna
douse my entire body with
rubbing alcohol light and all my whole
body on fire do a standing backflip and
i guess the 90s were a different time in
albuquerque because they were like right
on you're in
you know yeah i really like to get like
right on you're in done
and uh my sister was there holding the
wet blanket to wrap around me to put me
out wow
i think i've also seen footage i'm
pretty sure it's you filming cindy comes
in wakes you up
walks you outside and you just do a
backflip in the front yard it's like it
felt like this is kind of like a ritual
of like
wake me up in the morning i'll just do a
backflip first thing or something like
that backflip in and of itself just to
backflip on its own was kind of like
whatever and so i was just looking for
ways to make it cooler so like light my
whole body on fire and i thought what if
like i said cindy like come in you know
before i'm awake like film me sleeping
wake me up and and say okay do a
backflip
and uh
yeah i should do something with that
footage i had my teeth all broken and
[ __ ] yeah but yeah that was that was my
sister nobody else was like you know
stoked to help me like and then after
clown college two you were like doing a
bunch of clown tricks there's like an
hour of footage where you're trying to
get this one trick right and you're like
okay like you hear you just being like
so supportive but also just sitting
there the whole time filming it is like
a task you know
yeah and and and because cindy
was
so instrumental you know so like like
without cindy's support i never would
have gone to clown college you know i'd
who knows you know i mean i probably
would have gotten somewhere but
cindy uh was was in my corner and uh and
and i'm just forever grateful for that
yeah i really really genuinely am
forever grateful for that
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you